great ideas don't make
great movies they can help but great
movies need events right and conflict
and characters
what's your writing process
my writing process
it starts off with
procrastination and i gotta say this
because every writer does it um and it's
terrible i don't recommend it
but
no let's be honest
writing starts off with uh
an idea right um
and you get excited about this idea and
you have to write it down
again i'm talking about writing on spec
um it's very different if you're coming
in to write something or you know if
there's a pre-existing
let's start off with writing on spec and
i'll answer the question separately if
you know about writing
based on someone else's material so if
it's my own script um there's an idea
and uh i'm very excited about it and i
need to write it down and i need to
capture it as best as i can right so i
usually might be on my computer or might
be just um
hand written right and i'll take a
notebook and i'll start writing
and of course i'm very satisfied with
that but then you realize okay this idea
is not the story right everyone has a
great idea but then you have to break
down break it down into characters and
beats
and it's so much more complex and of
course it will change
because
i id great ideas don't make
great movies they can help but great
movies need events right and conflict
and characters and so on
um so you start breaking at some point
you start breaking down a story you get
very frustrated because
now it's real right
ideas are up there flying in the air but
then you're breaking it down and now
it's got it's gotten real
so you start breaking it down
and you explore characters separately
and if some people do backstory
i discover backstory as i go along
some people start off from theme i love
theme by the way it's something i think
about
i tend to i think of theme as a question
you know some people some people will
use words right like um
love
full potential right
i don't know what to do with with those
words and you know
in terms of practical writing like it's
a story about love
sure i mean but what do i do with that
so to me themes are more more of a
question more of a specific
question
um
you know it might be a movie about
sports
but then the theme is
um
how does it feel like to not be
recognized by your father right for
example so i mean
it's something i can relate to and then
i can explore and
the story is an answer to that question
in a way
so um
once i have the idea i start breaking
down separately character and backstory
um
the world right
if it's period i have to do research
um and i love research
um i actually love it so much that i
would spend
my entire life just doing research
i love going reading books watching
movies going to library you know
sometimes
great the new york public library has an
amazing archive
and you go there in the back with your
little gloves and then you just spend
hours going through original
letters and
i i had a blast doing that so research
not too much because at some point it
can drive you mad so at some point you
got to stop with research and start
making things up
and once you have like the world the
characters the beats
and now you're ready to start writing
um
if it's you know if it's based on
someone else's material then um
[Music]
well i guess instead of coming up with
the beats you're trying to find those
beats in the book or the source material
and the characters the beauty of
adaptations is the characters are a
given
you know
still it doesn't mean that you're going
to take everything in there
you got to learn what to take and what
to discard of course
um a friend
who's a producer the other day was
telling me
that
movies are not novels movies are short
stories
um and and short films are like poems
so
you know there's not a lot of beats in a
movie even if you're doing a three-hour
long movie there's not an infinite
amount of beats novels have so much
material that you got to weed out
what stays and what goes
um
so it might seem like you have a lot of
you know
real estate to to develop your story but
you don't
um an average 100 minute movie is
i'd say about 36 to 40 beats
maybe maybe more if it's really
fast-paced but you only have a certain
amount of scenes in a 90-minute script
you know
you have 33-minute scenes again it's not
math but you know what i'm saying is you
really gotta pick
what you're gonna focus on
it doesn't matter if it's an adaptation
or your own work
for your script regarding timothy leary
since he had such a vast long life
i'm not sure when he passed away he took
his life correct he died yeah in the
late 90s um he was already
in his 80s okay
sure
how did you know what you what time
period or did you cover most of it well
actually it took me several drafts to
figure that out um
i knew it had to start in the 60s
the first draft i wrote the script
started in 1963 which is when he gets
kicked out of harvard
because he gave students
psilocybin and lsd
but then i realized i had to go back i
had to start it off in 1960 which is
when he gets hired at harvard harvard
because
it's he's 40 years old
uh he's going through a middle age
crisis his wife first wife has just
committed suicide recently
no one knows about this so i figured you
know i got to start at the beginning
and sometimes it's not easy to know
where the beginning is
um it's really up to you
so
i actually wrote i think like two drafts
that took place in 63
then i went back to 1960 which is the
current version
um
and then the beauty of it is you can
have at least five or six seasons if you
wanted
because every stage of his life is a
different whole different thing
harvard california new york
afghanistan uh switzerland
yeah
um
[Music]
but only i mean i wrote the first draft
based on the book and then i went to the
public
library in new york where there are
approximately
463 i think boxes of his belongings wow
his personal archive
and i you know i rifled through that and
i didn't get to all the boxes by the way
because that's insanity
i did go through a lot of them
over several trips
and you know it was
there's nothing i like better than
spending time with you know studying
original sources
right and then he had a subsequent
relationship
with someone that he cared very deeply
for didn't he but it's debatable whether
she was
hired
to spy on him um oh there was a
documentary that came out recently by
errol morris i think it's his fourth
wife joanna harcourt smith um larry had
several wives um
[Music]
well there was a whole debate i had with
the producer who was who's a friend of
mine and who was convinced that leer was
a saint
and i had to tell him
no he was this man was incredibly flawed
very responsible
we i think he's our way into the counter
culture and telling that whole story i
don't think we should use this man as an
example of anything
because he for for decades he talked
about the death of ego and he had
nothing but ego actually he was married
to i think five
amazing women
and he disrespected all of them and he
could never you know he could never love
them the way they loved him
and it's actually tragic
i know i mean
i hope none of the fans larry's fans are
listening because they're going to kill
me but um
i think he's a very contradictory man um
very you know he had the he had the
charm he could lure people in
um very smart
but i think the the the one in that
relationship the one who actually
transcended all that was richard alpert
who became ramdas
so in the show we have
uh leary who's uh
who's a voice of this whole movement but
in a way i feel like he's disingenuous
and you have
ramdas who actually did go to india and
transcend
ego and became this beautiful being